[تصفيق]
قدم الغرب لاوكرانيا اسلحه متنوعه بينها
الصواريخ هايمارس بعيده المدى وعاليه
الدقه ومدافع هوتسر ام
777 وساعدت القوات الاوكرانيه على تغيير
مسار الحرب خلال الصيف وفق صحيفه تيليجراف
البريطانيه تضاف لها صواريخ ستينجر
والصواريخ جافلين الامريكيه الصنع
وباستطاعتها مهاجمه المركبه من الاعلى ومن
الدبابات لدينا ابرمز الامريكيه التي
تتميز بمدفع 120 ملم ودبابه لبارد اثنان
الالمانيه مع توقع ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا في
الهجمات المستقبليه ودببه تشالنجر اثنان
البريطانيه ولم تظهر بعد في القتال
المباشر وهناك ما تعرف بمدرعه اي ام اكس
10 الفرنسيه وتسمى بمدمره الدبابات هي
مصممه للقيام بمهام الاستطلاع وتقديم
الدعم الناري قدم الحلفاء الغربيون لكييف
انظمه دفاع جوي متطوره حيث نجحت باتريوت
الامريكيه في اعتراض الصواريخ كنجال
الروسيه الاسرع من الصوت بينما اتحدث
موسكو عن استهداف منظومه
الطائره بدون طيار برزت ومن اهمها طائره
بمقدار التركيه وطائره التي تحمل قنابل
يدويه وهي طائره تجاريه طورها الاوكرانيون
في المقابل تملك روسيا اسطولا متطورا من
الاسلحه مثل طائره السخوي بمختلف انواعها
والمسيرات مثل شاهد 136 الايرانيه اضافه
الى الدبابات
62 المطوره وقد حصلت على اجهزه التصويب
المزوده بالتصوير الحراري وفي ميدان
المعركه صواريخ اسكندر وصواريخ كنجال وهي
صواريخ باليستيه فرط صوتيه استخدمت اكثر
من مره في هجمات روسيه
على الارض اربع مناطق على الاقل شكلت
محوره هجمات اوكرانيا او ضمن بنك الاهداف
محور
ويشمل جبهه بخموت حيث صرح مسؤولون
اوكرانيون ان قوتهم تقدمت نحو كيلومتر
ونصف فيها المحور الثاني ويشمل جنوبي
مقاطعه
وصولا الى حدود شبه جزيره القرم والعين
على جنوب ومدن اوغليدار
يقول الاوكرانيون ان روسيا في موقع دفاعي
فيزافولوجيا رغم ان مركز القتال لا يزال
في الشرق لا سيما
ويبدو الرهان الاوكراني على زابولوجيا
لاختراق الجسر البري الذي يربط روسيا بشبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمته موسكو الرئيس
الاوكراني قال ان الهجوم المضاد قائم
بالفعل بينما تحدث الرئيس الروسي عن تكميد
خسائر كبيره اما معهد دراسه الحرب ومقره
واشنطن فق ال ان المرحله الاولى من الهجوم
المضاد في اوكرانيا يرجح ان تكون الاكثر
تكلفه وصعوبه من حيث الخسائر في الارواح
وتدمير المعدات
[موسيقى]